[Music]
well delighted to have you here thank
you for making the time to talk to me
my pleasure I'm excited about it Miguel
was like you gotta get Sadie on I know
what a good quick brother little brother
he's so big I always tell my big brother
my little brother right he's not your
blood brother but you guys grew up
together
I wish we're gonna talk about who which
is a very cool and unusual upbringing I
think what's interesting about that and
we'll dive into it a little bit more is
that both of you created these massively
successful businesses that are really
driven by the core values that you grew
up with and are all about belonging and
community and connection you're doing it
in different ways but in many it's sort
of like they're they're an extension of
what you learned as kids growing up in
that community mm-hmm yeah absolutely
yeah yeah well why don't we start with I
want to I want to start with talking
about the conventional conversation
around Fitness versus the conversation
that you're having mm-hmm yeah um yeah
conventional versus the conversation
we're having
I just to step back I didn't use the
word fitness we've my husband and I
co-founded by three and 2008 is when we
opened I've been in the fitness industry
my entire professional career I fell in
love with it in the 80s like meeting
Jane Fonda in my living room with my mom
it just drew me in right away for
various reasons and when we opened bar
three we didn't use the word Fitness
because I had it anchored to negativity
and being a chore and something that I
didn't identify with and it wasn't until
about eight years ago or eight years in
that I took we took back that word
fitness and we're redefining it so what
is that redefinition and there first of
all I want to point out there's nothing
wrong with Fitness as we all know it
it's just it my relationship to fitness
was broken and so I needed a redefine it
and and I noticed that a lot of other
people do as well
well why don't we start with how it got
broken in your own personal experience
sure my my story I think I fell in love
with Fitness because to me it was an
answer to be badass and to show up
successful worthy attractive winning you
know and I love the feeling of
exercising and a groups a group exercise
always drew me to the table the fact
that I liked it and it would make me
better
it was really exciting I'm a high
performer hard wired clearly um yeah and
so that that really drew me in and and
ended up teaching by the time I was 19
years old I went to City College in
Santa Monica Santa Monica City I grew up
in Eugene Oregon I went to City College
found my way to UCLA started teaching
there fell in love with it there and la
is so body conscious I felt it was very
body conscious and I was not happy and
my body yeah and um and very
disassociated with my body and fitness
was my answer to get back in my body and
and shape up so that I would belong and
have friends and be seen and be worthy
that's really what the inner driver was
for me if I'm to be completely honest I
ended up running the instructor training
program there went to grad school did
fitness there at William and Mary and
then landed a job with 24-hour fitness
right out of grad school and worked
there for 10 years and was at the center
of this very successful fitness company
and this is pause there for a moment you
you get your masters in education from
William and Mary I mean first of all
like you moved to LA kind of on a lark
right like who's the idea you were gonna
go to Hollywood or what was the initial
impetus and moving to Los Angeles like
right out of high school the big one was
to get to know my dad for the first time
he lived there and he didn't raise me
and I've never called him dad he passed
away nine years ago but that was a big
one so I moved in with him and as an 18
year old got to know him right um
and I was also drawn in by I thought I
wanted to be an actor and then I
enrolled in my first acting class and
did not like the actual acting part I
think I just wanted to reinvent myself
right so well this is the land of that
you came to the right place for that but
then you you you sort of find your way
to the fitness world at some point and
you also fall in love with learning in a
different way that was distinct from
your high school experience from what I
understand yes you did your research yes
dude I love it I know you do I really
appreciate that yeah so I first of all I
went to alternative schools in my
primary years and art focused lacked the
basics aha unless you were innately
driven towards math and grammar and
linear a lot of pottery right yeah I was
drawn to the arts and so that the school
allowed me to do whatever I wanted to do
got to middle school didn't have the
basics and on top of it I had low
self-esteem around my ability to achieve
in the academic world in this linear
world and then got to high school and
survived just on like you know social
acumen and having fun sitting in the
back of the class acting like I didn't
care even though I did I just didn't
want to try because I had such a fear of
failing right and and how much of that
was a reaction to the alternative you
know kind of lifestyle that you were
living at home in this community of
women and my my mom my mom and her best
friends raised us collectively basically
and they are all single moms and they
raised this kids to collect collectively
and to their credit which i think is a
beautiful thing as we as a family
celebrated mediocracy like you did not
need external measures of success to
belong in our family it that was just
sort of nice but that's not what matters
what's going on inside what was your
dream last night you know how are you
feeling what's your gut instinct you
know I was always validated for my inner
world
old and the outer experience was not
measured mmm that was our practice at
home right then you go into the real
world you step into school and it's all
about external measures that's why I
think I was drawn to fitness because I
excelled there I am exterior my exterior
was accepted and and I'm was like well
if that's my worth that I'm gonna make
it even better
mm-hmm so I belong and seeing I have a
connection with other people right but
you didn't play you didn't play sports
I'm not a single sport never cheerleader
kind of but I have to say and I love if
any of the gals on my cheerleading team
are listening to this I love you all so
much and I do believe your inner
athletes but in the 80s at South Eugene
high school it was not a sport to cheer
okay kind of poetic and hilarious about
the fact that like Miguel becomes this
you know amazing basketball player and
you're a cheerleader we're so different
oh I know Americana there is a
reactionary aspect of that I yeah yeah
we're I mean I used to joke that we were
plain normal right you know we we would
go to school and play normal and then go
home to our alternative you know who we
really were and Yaman and your aunties
are still all together right yeah it's
greatest love stories are amazing it's
the greatest love story ever they still
in Eugene yes most of them hmm
yeah yeah they're um deer deer they are
my auntie mothers I mean I don't really
have um a title for them because they're
not really my aunts they're not really
my mother's but um you know with every
cell they are I mean I feel feel them
just as much as my birth mother yeah
it's interesting that we reflect on that
as being kind of off kilter when in
reality it's much more natural than the
way we live now you know and I and I
feel like you know we're experiencing
this epidemic of loneliness and and
depression and all these you know
anxiety related disorders and they're
rooted in our lack of connection
and our lost sense of community that you
know that upbringing kind of perfectly
you know encapsulated and prioritized
that's precise precisely what I've been
ruminating about lately is that it is so
intuitive to set shoulder to shoulder
with women around a fire think about
that
humans doesn't matter who you identify
with it is in us as human beings
involute to be in village to be around a
circle to be seen and heard and to have
a role that was important and what was
once very intuitive for all of us it is
still intuitive for all of us it and now
it needs to be intentional yeah you have
to go on a retreat yeah like you just
did yeah yeah which was so no pun
intended but full circle I was the
oldest woman there I was I'm 47 they
were mostly younger women and they were
going through this investigation of
dropping out in their own way like my
mom did in the 60s and to get back in
their bodies to own their power to be
connected again and and not
disassociated with their femininity
right and it was so special for me to
see them sitting in circle just like my
mom did in the 60s and and reinvent
themselves and me too I was a fully
participating but from a different I
think a different point of view because
I grew up so differently than everyone
it's interesting how these things go in
cycles like yeah there was the Summer of
Love and everything that that birthed
and then that kind of went away and
we're seeing a new wave of that
happening now yes and I think it's a
reflection of kind of you know what
we're missing there's something innately
human our intuition is saying like I
need more of this I'm gonna
intentionally seek it out yeah how many
times have you gone to a dinner party
for example longing for community and
connection breaking bread with people
and leaving feeling depleted
disconnected even more lonely and for me
it's it's the dinner parties exists you
know the social things exists like I'm
around people all the time but leaning
into intention of really connecting
deeply setting the phone down asking a
real
and listening intently all those things
we practice being distracted all the
time
and we're really good at that yeah and
my big aha is that we need to practice
active listening
connecting sitting shoulder to shoulder
really seen and hearing each other to
get back to that that belonging we all
have and not longing to be to be
connected yeah I think it's in it's sort
of intuitive in the feminine to yearn
for that and reach out and take action
on that I think it's more difficult for
men although just as much needed I think
it's harder for guys to say I'm gonna go
on a retreat with a bunch of men and
we're gonna talk about our feelings yeah
but I think that that is that's
something that I mean I love to do and
have done and I think it it it I think
embracing that feminine aspect of being
male is something missing and we all
have feminine energy and we all have
masculine energy I have a I have
arguably more masculine energy than my
husband like I show up all the time on
stages like that's very masculine I you
know I'm very out there in the world
that way we all have both and in my
experience in fact this just happened I
presented at the how I built this summit
and I I did something out of my comfort
zone but I just knew it was going to
work I had about hundred people in the
audience and I did a session on
leadership circle which is how I've
taken this idea of connection into a
business environment and with a little
vulnerability and most of the audience
were men and because I couldn't hold
circle with a hundred people I did a
fishbowl circle and I I had no idea if
people were gonna bite but at the very
end I said okay so I'd like to have some
volunteers to join me on stage and we're
going everyone's gonna listen so we'll
all be part of circle but six of you are
going to share this question and I gave
him a juicy question and the men's
aren't hands shut up they got up on the
stage they were 50 I did fifty fifty
fifty percent those who identifies male
and female and my in my end
boner ability was equal and beautiful
and awesome and inauthentic it wasn't
but everybody used their own link
and in my experience when you invite it
men show up all the time yeah you gotta
get permission yeah did you open that by
leading with your own vulnerable story
yeah I kind of set the stage yeah and
provide that permission the whole part
of my first part of the presentation was
really holding the space and speaking
and I think this is where one of my
unique genius is that because I played
normal so well I I do get normal like I
don't talk whoo whoo
I am very practical and except for the
crystal you just put down on the table I
know but it was sneaky your other
crystal friends yeah and I wanted to
hang out in the crystal circle over
there yeah I think that it isn't woowoo
and that I did lead with that it's
intuitive we're human beings we all long
for it and I ask questions have you been
around the boardroom and been frustrated
that your voice wasn't heard or
self-aware that other people weren't
being heard and seen hmm are you lonely
at work even if you own your own
business I know I was I'm the besides
that you're in Los Angeles when I first
moved there when my company was at the
center of a most successful it's been
and it seemed like it we were just
booming on the outside and doing so well
I was the most lonely I've ever been in
the center of my own company and I think
loneliness is an epidemic in the work
environment so as soon as I invited
those questions it's like yeah yeah yeah
you know and then and then you add the
measures of success around it like when
I started to when I had the AHA that I
needed to bring the circle into the work
environment that's when things up but
not that's when innovation happened
that's when debate happened that's when
trust and workplace awesomeness came
alive in my organization but you had to
get to a place where you were open
enough and willing to you know be on the
receiving end of difficult news yes yes
um really difficult about two years ago
I was taken on my knees I to start out I
I did it we've always done a good job at
bar three within training instructors
and our franchisees in a really open
kind of circle way we actually sit in
circle for every instructor training and
we have instructors come in from all
over the nation in the world now and the
first thing we say in circle is you are
all as much of a teacher as I am if I'm
leading the training we're the anti guru
model and your wisdom and life
experience is going to inform this
training and move us forward without
knowing one thing about teaching yet and
we go around and I ask everyone to share
what are you bringing to this experience
what wisdom are you bringing and people
will share I was a Division one athlete
I was injured and that my whole identity
around being physical was taken down and
i anchored fitness to shame and then I
found bar three and I figured out how to
be empowered in my buddy and I want to
give that back you know and my mom you
know you hear all these stories and
right from that beginning they're like
I'm part of this I matter we did that so
well with our product then behind the
scenes I was trying to follow the model
like okay we have got a boardroom table
now and we've got an executive team and
we've got accountants and financial
people and marketers and I did I
neglected that team I didn't put that
same intention into our headquarters
right and for a while there it worked
because it was the the first group of
phenomenal women that helped us kind of
run this move this forward then I
brought in other team members and as
things happen there's some a lot of
toxicity in the company and a shake up
and I was so identified with being a
beloved leader and and and that my worth
is attached to being successful right on
external measures right ironically that
even though my product is all about
going inside and being empowered from
within like my whole identity
unconsciously was about this thing felt
the uncertainty in the office so we sent
out a I literally googled healing survey
anonymous feelings survey ah helped me
you know
10 o'clock at night with tears stream
you know my face like you know was
going down at bar 3 and so we sent out
an anonymous healing survey about how
everyone was doing and the results came
back and there were stinging comments
about me personally
as a leader as is still triggering as a
person so I got it yeah it was
earth-shattering like it was my shakeout
moment now two years later greatest gift
because I had a circle of support and at
first I was like that's not fair how
could they they suck and then I was like
I'm gonna sell this damn company can I
swear yeah of course I'm sure you could
have gotten that kind of feedback from a
bunch of friends too who would tell you
oh you're right and they're wrong and
all of that right so when you say circle
of influence what does that mean these
people didn't do that yeah that's why
they are good I have this group from its
entrepreneur organization it's a global
organization and I sit in a forum circle
once a month with other founders we're
all founders at the company like a YPO
common yeah and we're trained on it's
very much like I grew up it's just all
communication and no advice-giving and
reflecting back experience sharing I
texted them I had the wherewithal Deneau
detects in my mind's eye it was a I
couldn't leave my house I just I was
ready to just bail they showed up with
tater tots my favorite food and sat
around the kitchen table with me held my
hand and just listened and saw me and
one woman sue does research for a living
and she said well let's look at it let's
not let's not push it away let's really
look at it you know so she helped me
process it from a data perspective and
to help me get the emotion out my other
friend Pat said in my experience when I
got feedback like that I owned it and
just being honest about owning that
feedback is where I learned and grew you
know that the combination of those two
factors changed me I then took a minute
and I stepped back and I looked at the
data I took out the things that were not
productive
you know the stinging comments and that
weren't real
don't like your haircut yeah whatever
yeah like that stuff and um and then
really investigated the real things that
were hard for me to see and I realized I
can't fire myself we're were so loners
we don't have board of directors we
don't have anyone no one can fire me
it's my job to do the work and to show
up for my team so I sat on the hot seat
and invited anyone else but I was the
only one that did it i sat on the hot
seat in front of the company and share
it my whole company and shared the
results and I put together an action
plan with measurable KPIs and how I as a
leader was going to improve in the next
four months once a month we got together
let's look at this again let's look at
this again the productive things yeah
and through that whole thing I gave
everybody permission to fail hmm we
weren't striving for perfection anymore
letting go of that perfectionist
mentality I mean it's a it's a
fascinating inflection point because you
have this choice because you can't be
fired you're either gonna take the
autocratic route and just clamp down and
it's my way or the highway or you're
gonna go the vulnerable route and say
okay like let's let's heal this let's
solve this let me you know help me help
myself so I can help you yeah and I
would imagine just the doing of that
like the reading of the the feedback in
front of everybody
would have shifted the tide and Agenor
like you know a level of trust and
empathy going forward I think it was
triggering for some people there was
some a gazettes after that I feel like
this is anonymous and then now you're
getting up and you're reading them all
but nobody knows me of course and we
made it so it was really safe like that
that part we did we did adjust we didn't
do actual feedback sentences for example
word clouds and that kind of things so
it wasn't and I think that that there
were other leaders in the company we all
could have all of us owned the toxicity
on the company it's a shared
responsibility and all I can do is own
my own and the other thing I
invited is please be compassionate I am
I need your compassion you know I need
stumble - mm-hmm and I I know that women
who are in power now are overly
celebrated in a way in that and believe
me I hope I'm the only reason I kept the
title CEOs because I want to hold that
but because there is so much emphasis on
women coming into power that way and to
corporate America and having big roles
were higher on the pedestal and further
to fall mm yeah and probably more under
a microscope and then not Fitness on top
of it and the exterior pressures of
Fitness yeah well if I could say two
things I mean the firt the first thing
is like no matter what I take away from
that is a lot but one of the things is
no matter how successful you are you
have to remain teachable right you have
to like set aside your ego and and
remain open which I imagine becomes more
different you become more calcified the
more you kind of rise up that chain and
then the second thing being I just lost
my train of thought on that what was it
I forget one thing it for me is
redefining what success means uh-huh
success is not about getting there we
know that I think we all know that it's
about um it's for me success is about
being authentic to my values and showing
up that way yeah as a practice over and
over and over again and you can do that
through work you can do that through a
sport you can do that through anything
we do in life we can embody our values
as a practice and if we if I do that
that to me is success and not becoming
the CEO not having hundreds of studios
not having that's not success it's how
I'm practice dealing with resilient how
I love learning how I have curiosity how
I build confidence how I have strength
and if you and are you living in
alignment with those core values you
establish this to begin with I mean I
just remember my second thought which
has to do with
that kind of lion ization of the CEO and
and perhaps particularly the the female
CEO and I think that's great and it's
amazing that we are celebrating these
you know empowered women in that way but
I think along with that my observation
is that there's a mythologizing that
happens and that puts pressure on that
individual to like live up to a certain
standard of behavior and operating
practice like I think I read somewhere
where you were asked like what's your
morning routine and you feel like you
have to answer it in the way that
they're expecting you answer it and and
you're not allowed to answer it honestly
and that's a divergence between
expectation and authenticity so as
somebody who's so deeply intuitive and
whose business is really birthed out of
that intuition when you depart from that
and create dissonance there's like a
there's a fracture there right that
creates these ultimately leads to these
inflection points that are either gonna
break you or you're gonna return to that
voice and that isn't just in business
that's in everything and I do think that
we embody that that's where injury comes
that's where illness comes when we are
disassociated with our values and not in
alignment with them our bodies react and
if you look at Fitness as an analogy I I
just over and over again what we teach
in the in our room at bar 3 is such an
analogy of life we there's 60 minutes of
moving together as a group in aligning
our body with intention foundation
lining the body up getting into posture
in a in a way that with integrity but
the real work is looking inside and
figuring out what do I need right now
and then honoring that and moving in our
way and taking shape in your body in a
way that's right for what you need when
you're in a group the expectation is
that you're looking outside yourself and
you're copying what everybody else is
doing on top of these conditions that
full plank on the floor is harder so
it's better and it's gonna get me where
I need to be so I need to do full plank
but if you're doing full plank and you
have like burning risk pain maybe plank
is better at the ballet bar and if you
stand up at the ballet bar and
everybody's up that's on the floor
that's literally and figuratively a
practice of standing up for yourself and
honoring
your body needs and honoring your values
like I'm body wisdom taking care of my
body and not disassociating with it and
trying to fight through it and that's
what I think the real work is is
practicing that over and over and over
again I think I heard also read that you
open the class by saying you know we're
gonna take you through this hour-long
experience and I'm gonna say a lot of
things or the instructors gonna say a
lot of things but the most important
thing is that you listen to yourself
right like you kind of set that tone
that that provides that like kernel of
empowerment for the individual because
we need to practice that we all know
that we all know when we set quietly
there's those moments you know your
inner self your inner knowing is it's
important and that when you're aligned
with your inner note knowing things work
out you know because you start to make
choices that are in alignment with that
inner knowing but we get it that just
gets so quieted life rights on us and it
pushes that voice down down down down so
it gets softer and softer and softer and
softer and softer and um I was just
talking to my mom about this I'm gonna
drive over that she's like yeah I'm
still working on that like we're still
working on it like you just it's such a
practice to listen and what I love is
intersecting my mom was intellectual
they they were so intellectual they
studied Carl Jung and so their entry
point for self-awareness was dream
analysis it was still it was sitting in
a circle talking about dreams where I
get that is in movement actually using
my body to understand that like that my
inner self can show up in different ways
physically and I think that's so
important back to the metaphor is that's
when we show up at a presentation when
we show up for an interview when we show
up for the race whatever it is if we can
show up with that authenticity then it
it's you're teaching you're literally
teaching everybody else to do the same
day and it's not a place that you arrive
at it's a pretty it is a practice just
like Fitness is a practice and we were
talking in the kitchen beforehand and
you were tasting Julie cheese's she was
sharing a little bit about her business
and you were saying yeah and
it's here but this is a practice like
this is the beginning but this is a
practice that has no destination yeah
the cheese is on the table she did it
it's amazing
by the way but it's arrived she just
launched it but it's not done right it's
just gonna keep going and going business
as a practice yeah
I'm life as a practice I also like
interchanging the word practice with
exercise because explain that like we
exercise our right to do things we
exercise justice we exercise our ability
to nurture to mother we exercise all
kinds of things including our bodies and
again that intersection I think is
important to remember when you're
exercising you're exercising something
else and you're not just exercising your
muscles joint mobility posture
connection endurance
you're not just exercising that you're
exercising so much more yeah and that is
when we do all three of those things I
think of it as physical exercise
connectedness mental exercise
connectedness
and the third that's really important is
social connectedness exercising social
connectedness
hence the three in bar three cuz
somebody got through yeah that's good
right yeah my favorite number all right
so so you moved to Los Angeles you fall
in love with not only learning but group
exercise you going to UCLA graduate from
UCLA you go to William and Mary you get
a master's degree and then you get this
job at 24-hour fitness which is in the
dream city that you wanted to move to
San Francisco so walk me through the
experience of kind of you know joining
that organization and and and what you
learned and how that kind of created the
foundation for what you later created
yeah and just to close the loop on the
academic story I went to City College
right out of high school I didn't even
take the SATs I was not the most likely
to lead yeah so you go to Santa Monica
College can you get can you get into
that without an SAT or did you have to
take that it so it was so easy and so
inexpensive and it was great
III was great in that it was hard
because there wasn't social
connectedness
for me because there wasn't refresh
first yeah so that was I was really
lonely but I did um I did have some
beautiful teachers there who sparked a
love of learning for me and that really
reminded me that I've this curiosity and
curiosity matters and then the grades
come then I got into UCLA so close that
way that's an important story because I
think kids these days are it's something
Mike it we both have teens my kids are
so pressured to get that 8 plus a plus
plus plus and do all these things to get
into the college and to make it it's
gonna yes so many ways yeah yeah yeah so
many ways that's a whole other podcast
week yeah exactly
so San Francisco I landed a job with
24-hour fitness and thought I'd be there
maybe for two years it was an exciting
job right out of grad school I ran all
the group exercise programming for I
think around 20 gems
it's an incredible first job yeah really
is kinda than like teaching fitness
classes it was really your first job
right yeah really really remarkable I
was 25 years old uh-huh and the family
it's not like you even get your masters
in business like you were in educate
like how do you even get this job well I
did do fitness as my I I ran the fitness
instructor training program at UCLA and
I did the same thing at William and Mary
so I thought I was gonna run College rec
program fitness I so I think that really
helped and I really loved teaching
I was a you know I still I still shine I
love teaching cause you still teach
classes at your organization yeah I love
teaching yeah love being a student love
teaching so landed that job and it was
quite the ride I uh I ended up working
for the founder and CEO he's since left
Mark Mastrov for many of those years and
he such an entrepreneurial spirit and it
was really exciting working with him so
I really learned the business yeah like
how many gyms did they have when you
started and then how many ways I believe
around 20 and then when I left I know it
was 430 global yeah yeah and you were
involved in that expansion right
traveling to all these crazy place all
over the world right
and I also helped mark with some of his
other portfolio not associated with my
bar fitness so I was I I mean I just met
so many interesting people all over the
world exploring fitness and fitness as a
business and and whoa was it ever
successful and lucrative and an exciting
big booming industry right basically
you're going to business school to learn
everything you need to know so
ultimately launch bar three but this
gets back to inflection points you know
this is another big inflection point
because you could have you know stayed
there longer and continued to thrive in
that environment but something was
leading you in a different direction hey
I wasn't thriving in that environment
thriving financially I was thriving
financially yeah Chris and I finally
made enough money to buy the house and
we had two kids and Chris you met and
then recruited him into mark did I mean
yeah it's the way of doing that we had
one lunch and suddenly Curt my husband
or was working with me but right I'm so
I'm sure you get a lot of questions
about what it's like to work with your
husband but you've never known
difference it's been our dance the whole
way yeah it's been really really worked
well for us uh yeah I um yeah all the
things like on the exterior it was
awesome I and I had this really
interesting opportunity to potentially
go run yoga studios which I love yoga
and do all these interesting things and
we I just wasn't happy in my own body
during that era and I was not
identifying with Fitness the product
that we were selling and I had a lot of
shame around it explain that I'm sitting
in meetings with all these people
learning about these crazy numbers and a
crazy growth of our company I'm also
learning from all these amazing
consulting firms and the statistics and
data that our health is on the decline
so as the industry is booming our health
is declining significantly and so that's
confusing right I'm always like obese
because rates are going
fitness as a product and service was
invented in my mind 1980 obesity has
doubled since 1980 the health club
industry has more than that upper right
corner year-over-year it's a
billion-dollar industry - what is not
working here Fitness is working Fitness
when you study it in a lab you've
studied it in your body I have - it
works
Fitness is not broken Fitness is good
what I have discovered is that our
relationship to Fitness is broken and
there is so much shame in that
relationship
how predominantly to this day Fitness is
sold is that you start and before a
picture and then you do the products and
services in a certain order and you
become the after picture that's how it's
sold there let's look at that for a
second the before and after that if you
think about an after that's in the
future its imagined it's not real
there's nothing real about the after
picture and literally when you see a
before and after picture which still is
prolific and that's what sells it's
someone else and how they how they have
achieved a physical measure of success
sometimes there's a diarrhea behind it
that's like how I feel as well but it's
often a physical manifestation so we
can't ever get to that person and by the
way that person is not that person
anymore either
there is no presence yeah in the
before-and-after picture there is no
presence than that and there's a shame
in that when I became part of the
fitness industry and started bar 3 with
this awareness our central core value is
committed to real and I fell into that
trap I ended up signing a book deal that
I signed my rights away with imagery
they Photoshop me almost beyond
recognition and they sold that picture
which is a ridiculous picture of myself
ridiculous they took away my veins on my
hands my wrinkles on my hands that was
the most for me the most disturbing part
because when I look at my hands I see my
grandmother like double-jointed smoking
her Benson & Hedges like just like I
feel like my grandma when I say my hands
I see my mother in my hands they they
took away my laugh lines that gave me
breasts they gave me green
instead of blue they turn my hair more
golden and they did this odd that was
like what if I told you you could get a
lifted but and thin thighs and all these
things without barely moving a muscle I
mean it was the most ridiculous this was
in the phase of memory and and you kind
of the anti guru suddenly finding
yourself in the position of becoming the
new guru because there was there were
people invested in and blown up and and
making you a thing and not after look
you know because it literally wasn't
before and after they cuz they Photoshop
me it's like the after right imagine not
real I think we all know that now it
we've come a long way like the
photoshopping you know that it's more
disturbing now because social media it's
the girl next door it's not the Guru
anymore with a hundred takes and maybe
some filters right so now it's even more
confusing because it's quote-unquote
real but not really and the message is
confusing but in that moment I realized
well you can't see what's going on on
the inside on the inside I had chronic
low back pain I was depressed I wasn't
present with my young children and I was
I was witnessed to myself being
manipulated to look younger to saw and
whatever to look something else other
than I am so Fitness has been sold on
you are not whole yet if you do these
things you'll be better and and every
year there's a new idea and a new fad
and a new product and a new supplement
and on top of it there's this extreme
nature of fitness this more extreme you
go the better results you'll get so I
always think of like there's comfort
zone where you're in the center in your
comfort then there's brave space where
you go just outside of that comfort and
that's where in the body like you're
lifting must you're lifting weights
let's say and your body goes to fatigue
and failure and then it rebuilds let's
breathe space you're rebuilding your
muscle seem with our mental capacity
just going just enough so that you're
rebuilding building resilience building
strength and we do need that sand in the
oyster they make the pearl we need that
rub in our bodies physically but the
industry goes so extreme that we go into
panic zone so many people enter exercise
and they go tart too hard they get
injured they anchor it to pain to shame
to not looking the part and then we get
promised in one sweat sesh you're gonna
be skinny and beautiful and perfect
awesome right so there's just so many
ridiculous when we all talk about this
we're always like that's so ridiculous I
know better I know better but the world
says that all that's right
intellectually we know better but
emotionally we don't right so we've then
we it it they we it plays into that
thing if I want to belong if I look that
way I'll be attractive yeah I'll be
successful I'll be seen as successful
I'll be worthy I'll be happy I'll belong
and would if this is the question we all
ask ourselves all the time would if we
exercised to practice being honest in
our bodies forget about even like
feeling good in our bodies just honest
and that everything I do in that moment
is about honoring Who I am in my
physical self and what I need in that
moment and the more we do that you build
that muscle and that muscle carries you
through so many things in life yeah but
I want the before and after picture you
don't I mean like they that's a harder
sell it's not a it's a it's a much more
I mean you know when you think about the
word Fitness in and of itself is is
strange because part of it is that it's
aspirational but it's also this
pejorative you think of fitness and you
think about a treadmill and you know
underneath the fluorescent light and you
think about a bunch of people walking
around that look better than you and
you're feeling less then the whole that
whole industry is built upon preying on
people's insecurities to get you to join
and then not actually attend so they got
over subscribe yeah and that's broken
and not healthy and it works it's many
horse so it's legacy based and I think
that's why my my way is working too
right
and working our way up to that well yeah
you can not only me there's a movement
now of changing that story and that is
what drives me that's why we're growing
we have plenty in enough we have a house
we have kids they're in good schools I I
can travel I have an
i but the driving me is to extend this
movement right um because I think the
more of us that start exercising this
way the greater our opportunity is to
change those external forces to change
those messages it's not okay or normal
that most women have body image issues
that's not okay like we we just passed
that off now oh that's a phase all women
go through that that's not okay yeah
it's it's outrageous actually it's not
okay and we have the power business has
the power to change that we can rewrite
this story and we are rewriting it at
bar three and so many other a beautiful
organizations are as well and show I
love showing the business community that
we're profitable and we're growing and
we are people are choosing us because we
have a different story and that they are
getting what they need out of it and
coming back and then starting their own
concepts right so I do that's what
drives me at this point it is changing
you probably saw the New York Times
article about Mary Kane last week who is
the she was this she was arguably like
the next biggest thing in track and
field
yeah athlete and they made this amazing
like mini doc and and article about this
lindsay crouse wrote it for the New York
Times and it really it went crazy viral
and it created a conversation around
these issues so you see it at the
elitist level of sport I mean we're
talking more about you know the average
person the average woman the barriers to
entry yeah exactly but but but you need
those whether it's Amelia Boone who's
been on the show talking about her yeah
or Mary Kane and and and and and lindsay
crouse writing about these things at the
New York Times that are creating these
conversations that I think are gonna tip
culture and and and reframe this
conversation and get us into a healthier
place with all of this so powerful it's
so healing for all of us and I I think
that one thing we do all share is we
want to perform well yeah in life and in
sport and in our
we all want that and we want to be able
to sustain it yeah yeah just like
business right so if we grow a
sustainable business we'll be around for
a long time if I did hockey stick growth
and sold perhaps we wouldn't have done
so well in the long run so it's kind of
the same idea so you're at 24-hour
fitness for a little over a decade hmm
was there a moment where like I can't do
this anymore like how did you come to
the realization that you needed to blaze
a new path the first moment was when I
became pregnant and I I got back inside
my body and to my roots how I was raised
and realized that you know you can't
think a baby to grow my body just did it
and that my body has so much power and
wisdom on its own and I started to
practice yoga at home and started to
move in a way that was super freeing and
and so enriching and rewarding and then
I'd go into it even a yoga studio and I
didn't have that same freedom so that
was that was that was my moment where
I'm like maybe I'm not broken maybe the
fitness industry is broken like maybe
every more people have this shame it's
not just because I'm in the center of
fitness and I'm the face of fitness that
I have the shame we all kind of have
this right so that was that was like
maybe step number one for me and that's
what drove me into yoga and really
loving my kind of my heart is the
philosophy of yoga and then my husband I
made it we had the house by then we had
two kids and my husband was really the
catalyst he came to me one day with a
spreadsheet explaining how we could sell
our house in the Bay Area Hills and with
that that and we put all our money where
house poor into that house for anyone
who lives in the Bay Area knows like
it's it's like a major feat to buy a
house yeah and so that's all we did we
work to buy the house we got the house
and then he's like but so the house and
he is just like 10 years ago how long
this is now 12 years ago uh-huh let's
sell the house and with that chunk of
change let's move to Bend Oregon and
drop
and not work for a full year and not
traveler and just be home and simple
with our children and experience our
connection and our lives together and
it's still like chokes me up because in
that moment I realized so clearly that
that's how I was raised
yeah that's how I came into the world
would be like your mom yeah my mom
dropped out on purpose for that same
reason to reimagine being a mother and
being a woman and being intuitive and
more primitive in a way and those were
my formative years and I grew up with
this like hippie poor situation my whole
life I was like okay I've done the
hippie thing I want to be a rich super
cool I'm like you know mid six figures
so the the driver in me was he's are you
familiar with the in your game he's a
nine on the India gram he's a peacemaker
he blows I'm an achiever I'm a three so
we're a good combo so so he was he
experiencing this same disease yes he
was worse than me because at that point
Mark had a crafted this incredible job
for me I was doing special projects for
him at home so I was able to be with the
kids and do this cool branding work for
Fitness concepts and Chris was out in
the world like trying to make it happen
and his spirit was just declining he was
really unhappy and weird like is this
edit do we have to just keep playing
this game all this fitness is making you
unfit unfit it was yeah and lonely and
that is also when we realize loneliness
is a key ingredient to fit to be fit in
fact Cigna health care CEO just came out
with this statement that's so powerful
that in all the research now and
arguably Cigna has an incredible date
honor our state of well-being and health
that in order to thrive loneliness is
the key component yeah
mental connectedness physical
connectedness social connectedness and
we were basically missing kind of all
three in a way but the social
connectedness was huge for us so we took
that chunk of change and we started we
decided to start a business right
and that was bar three we moved to
Portland right why not Bend that's great
yeah Bend is great for Chris I need a
city yeah I I need a little more of that
and I say that and now we're looking at
moving outside of Hood River someday
because I'm ready for the country I just
need to go I needed to get that out of
me right so not to hit hippy but not too
hippy it's too early an urban boho
experience yeah like I'm an inner i'm an
inner hippie yeah the idea was to start
this the idea was not just cruise but
you were gonna start this business right
so when did you have when did you first
have the idea for bar three how long
have you been kind of harboring weed we
were thinking about running yoga studios
so we're on that we were already in the
studio mindset and I was teaching at the
daily method which is a lovely little
studio and loving the bar and wanting to
make something my own that that really
solved some other problems for me in my
body and in the mindset of it not being
at I didn't wanna be attached to
heritage yeah no no heritage we don't
have a method we're not a methodology
the we're attached to a practice of
recognizing imbalances and working
towards a more balanced state we're
attached to the idea of being empowered
from within and love of learning so our
concept is always changing I think it's
beautiful
Java heritage of ballet or a heritage
and Lodi Brook method or a heritage of
Pilates like I think those methods are
beautiful and I wanted to try something
different that was more evolutionary and
we could just learn from bodies and grow
and change and and that doesn't make
sense when you put that on paper that is
not a good business model and we didn't
care cuz we weren't gonna make work for
a year anyway so we let go of all
formulas I was talking your wife about
that it's like when you lead with
business you let go of the model the
business model and you lead from what
you think is right and then the model
catches up right and that's what
happened that's yeah that's exactly what
what how Julie kind of arrived at her
thang but I did read that you read a
book when you were at UCLA like when you
were like 21 or 22 do you know what I'm
talking about
which one create a visual as a
oh yeah that is really keeps manifesting
uh-huh
in so many ways I sat on my porch step
in LA with the Sun and I did this
visualization just free-flowing
visualization of myself and at the
center of it was the word alone but in
an empowering energetic way and I was
sitting in lotus pose with like monitors
behind me there was something digital
this is before this is like 1996 mm-hmm
before even any of us was really a real
thing and it was it was this
visualization of movement and
connectedness being alone with and I
think I had like pictures of other women
around me and but this idea of
practicing this idea of standing up
alone like being in solitude that was
that was the seed and it keeps me it's
to this day my practice right it's
amazing it really manifested yeah yeah
so then like I don't know 15 years later
or whatever yeah more than that
yeah that meant more than that I know
gosh 21 almost twenty yeah yeah 20 20
plus years all right so you moved to
Portland and you'd set about making this
dream a reality so what did that look
like like you you you start teaching for
free first right like while you're kind
of workshopping the concept and then
ultimately open up a studio like a
former ballet space or whatever we built
it out in fact my brother helped design
it
it was a family effort and it's it was
play it was fun we're in flow state
because we gave her again we gave
ourselves permission we rented a little
house went down Owen car tapped my two
little kids were with me all the time
and I rented a little space and Wild
Oats which is now Whole Foods upstairs
there was this I walked into this room
it's so you know one thing he just
things to start clicking it was set up
for my class a woman there Judy Mouser
was teaching a program called
Callanetics which is really big in the
80s which is similar it's isometric work
with a ballet bar so it was also
perfectly for me and I think it was $20
an hour to rent or something wonderful
and I created brochures and I'm around
town invited some women in and started
teaching and I didn't overly investigate
like my method I just started teaching
in tuition
yeah intuitively and I taught for like
close to 20 years right prior so I had a
lot of knowledge but I I rested that
knowledge too and really started to move
in ways that felt right and sequencing
the body towards balance and but
fundamentally in the bar tradition yes
yeah yeah that was my framing right and
and like bars become this huge thing but
you weren't the first there were already
organizations that were doing this and
competitors and things like that right
like so it wasn't like you were entering
into this trying to introduce people to
a brand new idea it was kind of in the
ether not like it is now but well it
great timing too and that was a business
educated business decision I knew bar
was gonna take off why did you know that
because it was sophisticated it was a
new take on fitness it was not high
impact it was about being strong it was
women's centric um it was small
community-based it was to music there
are so many things I left about it we
should probably define what it is yeah
yes so bar I'll talk about bar 3 but and
there are some things you want me to
talk about bar or bar 3 maybe bar first
and then how bar 3 is different in the
same sure bar originated by a woman
named Lottie Burke who injured herself
as a dancer and she therapeutically
rehabbed herself at a ballet bar and
created the Lottie Burke method and from
what I understand I'm not real close to
this heritage what I understand is some
key some of her key instructors moved to
New York
they started studios and this
proliferation of this methodology
started and back then all the different
bar studios I attended all founded by
women just shout out there and all
amazing I have mad respect for every
single one of them when I took classes
back then they were all very similar
mine's me of Bikram how other hot yoga's
will be the same 26 poses yeah
similar there was some nuances and
definitely character changes and culture
differences but there was a system
around it
you start with marches you do these
things so that took that took off in the
90s and then came came around in the
early 2000s and then you know it's been
it was the fastest growing niche for mmm
like five years mhm and all of fitness
and so that I I really I really liked it
and honestly I've been in the industry
so long it reminded me of a contemporary
Jazzercise something about it like the
way the teachers taught it was very kind
of robotic but in a good way like a
comforting way and you knew what was
happening and it was cool and it was fun
and it was efficient and you worked it
like head to toe without sweating too
much and there were just all these cool
things about it that I did like right so
you take that idea and then how do you
extrapolate on that to create your own
unique take I had chronic low back
issues and did not give myself nor did I
feel like the environment is conducive
to modify it like ballet it was very
much about being symmetrical and
following the method the the alignment
runs it similar to a younger yoga is
very focused on its precise this is
defined by God yeah we will not diverge
yes the dogma right it's so attached and
I always had this like rebellious nature
I wanted to do something crazy with my
body and it made me giggle because I'm
like in fact I did it once in New York
City at a studio I still cracked up in
the middle because I was dying we were
doing squats and I was dying and I was
in probably the best shape of my life
and there was a woman I kid you not it
was like nine months pregnant killing it
right next to me of doing I I couldn't
do it all and she was doing it and it
just it just made I burst out laughing
more out of joy and I said you've got to
be kidding him like said it out loud and
the instructor stopped class and she
said I'm so sorry she just really
distracted me it was so I was like gosh
we need a release and laugh about these
things and like give half permit
laughs and like stop ya holdin on so
tight part of the problem we would just
achieve achieve achieve get there get
there get there I'm the whole mantra was
taught versus a Tucker pelvis and like
these things and I had really chronic
low back pain and shame around it and I
but I wanted to do it and I kept pushing
myself into it and getting worse and
worse and worse and went back to that
memory of being pregnant and started
modifying I started doing a home and
plus I was going through yoga training
my mind was getting blown I trained with
Annie carpenter his frickin amazing and
everything she was telling me was
resonating but the actual movement of
yoga hurt my body it was I'm hyper
mobile I named our stability there
wasn't room for modifications even
though they said there was and flow
there's not really and so that that's
part of it is I wanted to create a
practice where the reason were
exercising is to acknowledge oh I'm
doing it like everybody else I should be
doing it like myself instead of trying
to copy and skips understanding that's
one of my favorite quotes I read that in
a book rework copying skips
understanding and movement is an
exercise of exercise and body wisdom of
learning about your body that's why I
love it now I have my attachment to that
versus it being a chore shame I'm not
good enough my injury is something I
should push away instead of work with
and um that's what Chris and I got
excited about so how can we do that is
that possible in a group environment so
you take all this experience that you've
accumulated over the years teaching to
basically assemble a new sort of loosely
held protocol assembling yeah assemble
it's constantly really are all this
experience that you have like growing
this massive gym you know organization
and you're kind of perfectly positioned
to like make this a thing right so when
did you know that this was gonna work
the minute I taught well I had a
during the pop-up classes because it was
just such a cool group of women that
were coming and it's they were enjoying
it uh-huh uh but once we designed our
studio which is around community and
bright being bright and light and
aesthetics are really important to me
and Chris both we've learned that over
and over again so creating an
environment we put a childcare gate in
the lobby because we had little kids and
so having that childcare component was
important to us and the sense of
community and connection and
relationship first exercise second um
when I wrote an email out to the various
people who had tried the class I had got
my certificate of occupancy that day I
said I'm gonna teach a class tonight if
anyone wants to come I had no idea if
people would come I think like 12 people
showed up they paid and they they took
the class with me and I it's I will
never forget that moment that first song
that first warm-up I just in my body
knew this is so this is so gonna work
this what was it about that that told
you that it was like validation of I'm
doing this my own way and they see
themselves in it and they love it they
they're a part of it with me like those
women I still remember them all of them
I remember the first woman who bought
her membership I remember all those
women they felt as much a part of it as
as I did I didn't feel alone in it I
felt very supported
and also the business side of it I knew
it was 2008 - as August 2008 when the
recession was at its worst
and but we all needed it so badly yeah
that's that's the moment in time where
the extraneous stuff like classes go out
the window right yeah in the gym concept
for sure because it's not revenue driver
right yeah I was always pushed like 24
hour fitness was exciting but group
exercise was dismissed it wasn't
interesting because it didn't show up in
the bottom line yeah it seems like
they've never been able to make that
work at the big chains because it's
fundamentally personality driven I feel
like I mean I don't know you're the one
who
/ lorded over all of that but whether
it's Equinox or these other huge
organization they all have group classes
but they don't create that that like
excitement that this the boutique
you know studios that are specific to
one thing are able to generate yeah in
my experience I felt a lot of enthusiasm
and excitement and those classes and the
big boxes yeah I have felt that I didn't
feel intimacy yeah and not is meaning
like connection and and like I didn't
ever feel like this is I'm a part of
that or things yeah yeah yeah I that's
echoed right over and over again with
other people so so you know this is
gonna work and there's a renewed or kind
of redoubled commitment to build this
thing in alignment with core values
right that you've worked very hard to
adhere to over all these years like what
are those core values and how have you
you know tried to keep the guardrails up
to protect that over time and while
you're experiencing all this growth and
all the kind of stuff that comes with
that well it's definitely a practice
because the business world is so
intoxicating and a lot of our values are
in or motivated and the external
measures and the external way of doing
things are often in conflict so our core
values I mentioned committed to real and
when that book came out with me being
Photoshop basically beyond recognition
and the words being manipulated on the
inside to fit the model there's before
and after pictures and all these things
that didn't feel right for me but I did
write I did it anyways because who is
who is the person in your ear that was
like pushing you in that direction that
didn't feel right is it just the the
dangling carrot out front like this is
gonna be if you want to really blow this
up like this is the way you do it and my
ego like this is great I get a book I
get to get out in the world and also my
responsibility to my franchisees to cut
because we're a small fish and then
and this would get us national exposure
get people in our doors you know I've
always thought having a book is like you
arrived when you have a book and I just
jumped on it without really
investigating like is this the right fit
for me right or what is the book that
you want what is it that you actually
want us it wasn't my book they had it
all figured out and they put my image on
it basically right and so that's my I
take accountability for that not them I
mean I could have said no but we ended
up pulling the book and not selling it
and the DVDs at the time and what have
we learned there is oh yeah if we are
definition of a core value is we are
willing to take a financial hit to
uphold the core value mm-hmm so it's not
just about driving the revenue it's
really like we're gonna we're gonna
scale back because this value is so
important to us right and that that over
and over again we've learned and I've
learned personally in my own body and
you know what works for me everybody
matters is another one of our core
values and that's how we talked about
the anti guru and being really open and
democratic and collective wisdom
listening to our clients listening to
our franchisees our owners all these
women who have invested their life
savings into this concept really
exercising that they matter that's a
practice it's hard to do but it's
something we really believe in and we're
really at leaning into more and more and
more and when it comes to everybody
matters the other thing I'm very self
aware of and working towards and our
whole team is investigating this is that
wellness in general is affluent white
women in my industry and and and I know
that's you're sitting across from me
that's who I am right I'm aware of that
and that is not healthy it it's I'm
healthy but that weren't we're not in
diversity is is not healthy in wellness
and so that's something we're really
leaning into is how do we really uphold
that value how do you we are asking a
lot of questions I don't have the
answers
radical curiosity around it and we are
asking questions amongst ourselves and
and with other people in our in our
network how do we raise diversity in
leadership first in our organization how
do we represent more equally all
throughout our organization at the
executive level all the way through our
studios into our instructors so we're
showing up as leaders in a diverse way
so that's step number one and um then
having these kinds of conversations just
saying it out loud and asking for help
and knowing that it really does matter
and it's more inviting
I love classes when I walk in and it's
just all where we go where we do really
well with everybody matters that we've
been focused on is body diversity age
diversity economic diversity we do those
three things really well right basically
the mission is I mean this is from your
website body positivity and and female
empowerment redefining what it means
what Fitness means redefining fitness
success did you know from the very and
and the franchise model is really
endemic to that right like that's a big
part of it did you know from the
beginning that you wanted to do this in
that franchise way yeah
so that you could empower these other
people to create businesses and empower
teams and other women like what was the
philosophy behind it yeah and we didn't
franchise that to my prior fitness so
that was the new model for us that was
owner all right um we had investment at
24 Fitness owned everything so we
decided on franchising because as our
growth strategy because it was really
interesting to us to think about having
a business partner who their investment
into the business their financial
investment they were they they were
going to actually be present in the
studio so we're owner operated they
invest and they uphold the product and
that commitment level was exciting to
Chris and I that will have empowered
business women and men putting their own
skin in the game and blood sweat and
tears I'm sure there were people telling
you don't
like go the private equity route you
want to be able to control it yeah you
won't be able to control the product and
the premium aspect of what you want to
create doing it that way
and the control is right but I don't
want to control people anyways even if
we own all the studios I don't want to
control people because over and over
again I learn that when I let go of that
our product becomes better yes it'll go
down this like it won't always be great
and exactly what I define is awesome but
there's always something to learn from
that and when you create an organization
of people that are allowed to try things
and be a part of it I'm usually in my
experience it gets better not worse yeah
that pushes my control freak button big
time we were talking about this in the
kitchen there is a you have to develop a
huge capacity for letting go because
your product as you were as you were
saying isn't a wheel of cheese or you
know a McDonald's hamburger it's a it's
a service and that service is delivered
by a human being mm-hmm and every human
being is different and they're gonna
have their own way of doing this thing
they you worked hard to create thank
right and you have to be like cool with
that in fact yeah you're encouraging
that well with so any creative person
will tell you you need structure to be
creative uh-huh we have structure we
have a very clear blueprint and
knowledge base around sequencing and
musicality and all the things we do give
them very very contained guardrails
around how but within that structure
insert you insert your your whole self
into it authentically choose your words
choose your own story in your own body
way to make this class relevant for you
I think it's so kind of sad to go to a
class and see an instructor robotically
teaching something that they memorized
versus really it creates a barrier
between me as a student and the teacher
they're not able to really connect and
be themselves
and so while it's scary and it can turn
sideways sometimes it usually creates
more connection and
and most people that we've surveyed like
I think that people wouldn't necessarily
say barre3 is the most technical of them
all but I think most people would say
Bar 3 has an amazing community uh-huh
and that's the key thing right like
that's what we care that's the heart of
the whole deal
one thing I read that I thought was
super interesting was on this subject
matter of you know these varying
personalities teaching this program is
this curiosity that you had around like
why are some classes more popular than
others and realizing that a lot of it
was rooted in voice inflection mm-hmm so
walk me through that I think yeah really
interesting we had the coolest AHA me
and a team of trainers we're always
bringing in experts for the body mmm I
had an observation going to classes that
people though the tone of someone's
voice and inflection created a more
contained kind of exciting exhilarating
class or sort of a not so interesting
class but it was technically at the
exact same class and what we learned and
I'm always self-conscious talking about
this because I start to listen to my own
inflection and I just did it this we
tend to in the box yeah oh my gosh women
but all we we are conditioned to end a
lot of sentences and question marks so
route your foot to the floor and then
we'll go to the mat and then there's
this upward and the question mark is an
unconscious am i enough are you with me
is this ok do you see me like there's
something in that my instructors that
were like route your feet to the floor
stand tall we're coming to the mat you
know that sense of like I am here I have
this voice and there is also a vibration
a kind of a they were using their
diaphragm so we brought in a voice coach
let's look at this and this voice coach
just got in there with us talking about
how voice is so much more than just
speaking it's our how we use our
diaphragm and we all realize that
in Fitness we've all been taught to suck
in our bellies and so a lot of us were
talking like this and we're talking in
our face voices because we weren't
breathing into our bellies because we
are afraid of expanding our bellies so
we even changed our retail line like to
more flowy tops and inviting the belly
to breathe inviting the diaphragm
inviting voice and that voice is another
way we show up in the world and that
what a certain service it's so beautiful
we have waist training for now not just
instructors as part of our instructor
training now but our my whole team at
the home office so when we stand up in
front of an audience our voice mirrors
our strengths and doesn't doesn't
undermine it and if you've been able to
measure the impact of those changes on
the experience of the person who's
taking the class yeah I mean our one
instructor in particular but it was
across the board we saw so many changes
her classes wait-listed no and she is
one of my top trainers and she was a
musical performer and just the most
incredible woman ever its she got it she
got into her chest voice and her
intimacy more versus performance and
it's nobody new it's not a thing you can
really understand I don't think any
client would ever understand that
connection but yeah I was a huge part
that voice and then we also really
looked at like all the senses heat sound
the vibe right it matters
what is the experience that you want
somebody taking that class that like
what it what do you how do you want them
to feel when they leave like what is it
that you're going for balanced embody
more balanced embody and empowered from
within if I was to just distill it and
that took a lot of time for us to really
work through what that meant but that
really is over and over again when we
get out to teach that's what we're doing
recognizing and balances working towards
a more balanced state not being attached
but more importantly being empowered for
my thin and feeling not depleted but
energized rewarded can
did in community the reason we love the
ballet bar is it wraps around the room
as a circle and I really believe in
formation matters
and that our environment matters and
when we're at the ballet bar we're
facing the bar so we're not seeing each
other we have this sense permission of
solitude and connectedness inside yet
we're shoulder-to-shoulder with other
people in the classroom with a clear
definition of that's our goal is to give
you permission to be your own best
teacher yeah and so there's something
about me being having people witness
that being near you while you're doing
it that I think reinforces that feeling
of I'm empowered in it it's okay like
people are seeing me and respecting that
I'm making different choices and they
are in my body right I should know the
answer to this but can a dude go to the
class is it women only I just assumed
it's a wit like it to me I yeah drive by
these bar and I was like well that's
that's off limits for me you know like
there's this whole shadow world of like
where I see with you know Fitness that's
like my development rope that I'm not I
know oh of course you would think that
we've been thinking but we've been
talking about this so the thing with
women's empowerment of course were a
part of that but yeah it is this is not
for women we all need to be a part of
this this is human conditioning how many
guys get over a few very few jams go I'm
not so much because he more he just
needs to get away from us he's like the
only man in our office there's like four
men in our office and like yeah he's a
big golfer yes i men for sure and we are
that's another part of our diversity is
raising more men within our organization
as instructors and leaders yeah I would
be like like if I had curiosity I'd be
like I can't go in there you don't have
to be flexible coordinated it's not
dance it's not ballet at all we it's
lunges it's isometric work it's um we
kind of we hold the body we move small
certain ways we move large we do with
its it's basically about it's a full
body balance workout that combines
cardio mindfulness and strength
conditioning in you know a specific
approach of teaching yeah so it's that
is not female right ain't it that's
right sounds good to me
yeah no there is a downbeat we love we
love music we have a very specific tone
with our with the music so there is a
sense of that but it's also you'll see
people going to the floor account or the
two count are the single everybody picks
you can pick your own beat I mean it
really it's yeah so you've got 140 honey
are you open right you own and the rest
of those are franchise choices I mean
that's ridiculous growth was there and
and back to this idea of inflection
points was there like an inflection
point or two along the way where it you
saw like this kind of hockey stick
growth or like to what do you attribute
like that level of expansion that I mean
we that's actually in our industry and
how strong our product is and how liked
it was we couldn't we could be double
the amount of studios we made a
conscious choice to slowed down on
growth when we could have sold you know
there was there was this moment we could
sell to private equity with the intent
if we did that that they we would have
this group of people supporting us you
could just really blow really blow it
out yeah and I can't imagine that moment
has passed though no it's like it's
still out there
I mean that's gotta be challenging you
know to think like oh my god I could
sell this thing in it's challenging when
we're fatigued honestly it's challenging
when we're fatigued if that's not a good
reason to sell because all of my owners
are like you know that's I so we're
really self-aware of that and we do the
work we investigate that all the time
and then when I say do the work we and
inner work what matters what's right
will be okay we have plenty we have
enough that's Chris and eyes mantra
plenty and enough and
then how can we magnify and optimize
what we have here because it is so
special I mean really it's just special
and and is there a way now to create a
growth strategy that honors what's
special about it that it is still heart
center now that we do have people
amazing magnetic leaders running it now
and I definitely see part three outside
of myself I didn't two years ago yeah
it's not mine anymore and we are right
now working with a wonderful executive
recruiter RINO doe to hire someone to
come in and help us around the company
so we are finding someone else to help
us who really enjoys scaling really
enjoys operating you know all the things
that Chris and I really mean someone
else to come in and help us with that's
our new growth strategy yeah I mean I
think an argument can be made that that
you know to some extent SoulCycle lost
its soul you know by selling it and when
you're in a position where you know
growth is basically the only important
metric and there's so much pressure on
you to scale at an exponential rate that
it's almost impossible to maintain the
kind of core integrity that be got the
thing to begin with yeah it's oh gosh
when that SoulCycle stuff came out I
sent the founders so much love and your
strength and power and they I do I think
I have mad respect for them and I
understand their choices and and and in
a way it's a gift and I hope they see
that way too
that it's okay like this is that's of
course like that's how business works
like we've all been that's how we've all
been told that's what success is and so
I don't think there's any shame and
that's three and I think there will be
rebuilding and they're a beautiful
organized I don't mean to throw shade at
them and no but it is that no doctor the
story no I get what you mean that was
the headline and I think there's always
an investigation under that like okay
that's the headline but that doesn't
need to be all of our story that doesn't
need to be our story let's change this
and I do believe that there are great
investment companies out there that
would at some
have to believe that at some point could
help you know I think angel investment
is probably a really good route for us I
don't know yet but we just have one
investor right the time for our fitness
yeah at the very beginning he's been
awesome advisor and not an active
participant and the operations that our
company our leadership in the gap you
know yeah and another big part of this
whole thing is the online subscription
aspect of it as well right mm-hmm
that's where I'm really leaning I'm
leaning into that big-time I think
that's so so good and something I really
want to grow into even more we weave
that side of our business has basically
drafted off the studios versus us being
really intentional about that growth
strategy which is really different than
the actual experience of being together
in a studio the beautiful thing about
working out at home is you have even
more permission back to when I was
pregnant at home to be in your body yeah
and confident and so I really love that
aspect and we want to learn more about
how we can reach people mm-hmm
the tricky thing there is trying to hold
on to that core value of community right
like there is such a thing as a virtual
community but it's not the same as the
experience of like bonding with human
beings and you know in an analog
real-life setting it's not the same I
think it's how we use that device that
it doesn't use us that we use the device
like we use our phones we use that all
the you know whatever it is in a way
that serves us and to be really clear on
that and that's in fact should be part
of our teaching right as we're teaching
the class or mining that do this so you
can then shut it off and be more present
as a mother you know win the race that
you're training for or whatever it is
yeah well as this CEO and Founder who
you know gets a lot of press and makes
all these fancy lists of you know the
top this and that do you think about you
know how you model yourself to the next
generation of female entrepreneurs like
in a mentorship context like how do you
think about that
well when all this stuff was going down
about me as a you know that that
anonymous survey and remarks about who I
was as a leader I was like I had a lot
of imposter ascent truth about being the
CEO and I am my brother actually said to
me because I said you know I don't I'm
gonna just step back I don't want to do
this anymore this isn't me I'm not good
at this and he said you keep that title
yes you are I mean we grew up together I
get also this yeah keep that tight do
not let go that title you're redesigning
it you're redesigning what it is to be a
CEO maybe you know and so in my mind
I've changed it to chief energy officer
mmm-hmm in that I'm tapping into that
and my feminine side and being okay the
reason there's a reason why there aren't
very many women CEOs it's because that
construct doesn't work for a lot of
women and the ones some women it does
because they're able to just as a
natural alignment for them but most
women obviously it isn't or we wouldn't
there would be more of us as CEOs so
maybe we need to redefine what that
means and so I that's the one kind of
feminist like side of me that's like
having to keep that title even though
I'm really looking at peeling back even
more in terms of executive leadership so
yeah and and I think more so than being
a leader I think a future generations
that collectively not just bar three but
all of us that are doing this kind of
work about letting go of external forces
and the measures that are attached to
those as defining our success and that
that's a practice to let go of that
external force and instead look inside
what really matters to me let me
practice that let me show up that way
whatever we practice would be wrong and
that if all of us do that more and more
and more than those forces will change
that the conditioning for our daughters
and their daughters and their daughters
and sons or however they identify will
be more in alignment with people being
empowered yeah that's more important to
me there's a tire trope
the female CEO which is that you you
have to literally be superhuman and be
this you know incredible mom and partner
and executive and you have to excel in
all of those areas and then you have to
field you know a bunch of questions
about how you balance being a mom with
running a company which you know a male
CEO never gets nobody's asking the male
CEOs like how they how they balance
being an amazing dad with running a
company you know there's an imbalance in
how we you know and how we treat and
think about women entrepreneurs yeah and
each of us as women whoever's listening
to this we have the worst part about
that is our own inner critic we have
that voice yeah yeah you're trying to
measure yourself yeah yeah oh my gosh
I'm not enough I'm not enough a mom I'm
not enough a wife I'm not enough a CEO
I'm not enough that is that voice that's
the only thing we can truly control we
can't control all the external forces
out there that's what I mean that
conditioned world but I think when you
you did a bunch of interviews after you
had that kind of Epiphany and you know
talked about the anonymous survey and
how this kind of brought you to your
knees and you had to rethink everything
and I think that was a beautiful like
offering to give the other you know sort
of female executives out there
permission to like take a breath you
know
yeah and realize that they're not alone
in this we're not alone
that is the best message over and over
again my mom said to me it struck me
like a lightning bolt when I was talking
around the phone Sadie you are always
gonna suffer you are always going to
suffer and for some reason that sounds
so sad right but for some reason it gave
me so much freedom as it's okay to
suffer and in fact it's human every
single one of us suffer every single one
of us has an inner product I don't know
why that was very freeing for me that in
combination with and I can change that
inner critic to inner warrior I have the
power to change that conversation in my
own mind in my own self and then talk
about it so other women have
and men have permission to do the same
thing when you look at at your success
like what do you think is has been your
greatest strength like what is
contributed to this you know incredibly
successful organization I I would say I
don't even consider a strength that's
just truly Who I am is being open and
vulnerable and Thank You Rene Brown for
bringing words around that because I
before I read her books and saw her I
didn't even know that was a thing uh and
that she just put such free meet she
framed it for so many of us and that is
true I mean that is I lead with it
courageous vulnerable heart and that's
how I cuz I was trained in that from a
very young age and inviting that into
other people's lives to do the same
thing is what I genuinely enjoy doing so
I think that's what's attracted people
to the organization it's why people stay
it's also why some people leave and
that's okay too well these things have
to find their own level yeah you know to
me yeah and when you look back you know
other than the things we've already
talked about like what are the some of
the lessons or mistakes that you made
that have been instructive and how you
kind of lead more mindfully now I really
had an ego in the beginning and even in
my language I'd say I how I wanted to do
it was and I wonder if I've been doing
not in this interview I've been really
thinking about that I did start bar
three but now it's we I mean 100
thousand percent and that's what I mean
I told you about instructor circle and
well matter but I don't think I was
always showing up that way I would
dominate conversations and meetings
interrupt or try to I was being fed this
message out in the world that you're the
face of this company and so I think that
that got to me and and knots been a good
reconciliation reconciliation for me um
that that didn't serve me at all it made
me feel awful
and just to remember that that's a false
sense of power that's not real and
that's been a really powerful journey
yeah and I really do think being a
business owner is a the most amazing way
to develop as a person if you lean into
it and you're okay sharing and growing
that way and now of course learning
active listening skills and just making
fun of myself and all the things um it's
so much more fun you know and things are
happening and it's freedom and and I'm
letting go
being an aging woman in the world you
know I'm told every day not to age don't
age don't age don't age and I think that
I was trying to overcompensate you know
for that and um that's been a whole new
thing is just being okay aging and
really yeah you wrote a piece about that
mm-hmm
I talked about I love talking about age
yeah I just was with my godmother who is
the oldest of my mom's friends um who
was truly my spiritual mother and I was
in bed with her when she passed away
there was 12 of us around the bed and I
was in with her and my hand on her heart
and it was the greatest privilege and
gift and um what I learned in my body in
that moment this really is life is
finite energy is finite and that what an
honor to age what an honor and to be
present and remember that is so
grounding and and so I'm fascinated with
aging and death and everything right now
like I cannot stop thinking about death
being a part of that experience was um I
don't know it was it's forever life
doing you sound exactly like Julie in a
room and cleaning it about 40 you need
to eat some cheese that is talking
about
that's amazing yeah I think it's unique
to be in the kind of health and wellness
space and also have a healthy
perspective on the finality of this
experience an appreciation for its
temporality and and to just kind of fall
in love with you know this journey of
getting older you know as opposed to
combating it and fighting it and it's
it's I think it's a you know it's part
of this more macro conversation that
we're having about holding things
loosely right as opposed to like the
fitness hold it tight and push it hard
and you know fight and you know claw
your way at every step rather than being
more in the allowing you know and the
empowering yeah well the other thing I
want to talk about just sitting across
the table from someone that I admire so
much who is the most incredible athlete
you know your story is so so so amazing
is that I think I'm interpreted often as
oh that's soft and sweet and my and it
doesn't mean that it's not hard work
yeah like all of what I'm talking about
I think has a lot to do with being an
endurance athlete for example there's
nothing wrong with wanting to win yeah
there's nothing wrong with the results
in the pain and like that the resilience
and the grit and the pushing through and
the healing heart that that hard work
right and like I just think that every
one of us can practice that in a
different way and that there's just
there's not one way to do that but it's
always brief space that when I was
talking about brave space I my favorite
quote is the sand and the oyster that
makes that pearl the rub and so like
with barre3 it is challenging you do go
to fatigue it does it is a struggle and
then it's learning to breathe through
that struggle and and look at it without
judgment or shame and then work all the
way through it I that's one thing that
happens in like like my friend Anne says
I'm your she's my I'm her woohoo friend
she's like you always bring the
thanks for bringing the woowoo and we
were talking about how whoo-whoo can
sound so soft and easy and I get what
she means by whoo and I always say I'm
whoo
I'm not whoo-whoo I'm like half whoo
[Laughter]
whoo kids we need a new word yeah
because there's a there's a different
way to frame it which is to be a Jedi
warrior you know what I mean like you
have yeah you have to be like rooted in
in some of these kind of age-old tenants
that have to do with surrender and
allowing but are actually envel nor
ability mm-hmm and and when to lean into
them and when to be in action and it's
that interplay that balance that ballet
between the two that that you know
creates the person that can not just
manifest the big vision in the
three-dimensional world as you've done
but do it with grace and humility you
know and and and all of those things
yeah right yeah you know and when you're
when you're saying when you're when
you're describing me like oh this this
athlete and all this sort of thing like
I'm just sitting here thinking about my
version of your story which is yeah you
can find pictures of me on the Internet
where I'm completely shredded you know
and I look ridiculously fit in a way
that's inaccessible for people but
that's not how I look right now you know
I look like that for five minutes when I
was training two years straight for a
crazy race and then that was over with
do you ever look at that and kind of
want to like go back to that yes and no
I mean that's part of you know on the
subject of aging you know it's part of
part of this for me is is embracing
where I'm at right now and being okay
with that like if I'm constantly
measuring myself like you know by a
yardstick of what I look like ten years
ago right before a race that I put
everything into then I'm gonna suffer
more than I need to you know and and
Julie's always saying like you just you
have to do like you have to go out and
trail run and do these things that you
enjoy doing for the love of it not for a
performance goal or because you have an
agenda but because it's who you are yes
and it doesn't have to be about a met
right who you are right now yeah and
and and you know so for me it's like oh
people you know I bump into them and
they say oh did you run 50 miles today
or how you know like no that's not you
know I'm podcasting and like I haven't
taken a break in seven years and I'm
like grinding like crazy working seven
days a week and now I'm doubling down on
that because I'm gonna take my first
like real sabbatical in December for the
first time in many years but that means
that my workload now is double or triple
what it normally is right so my self
care regimen is like out the window
right now trying to get all of this done
and it goes back to that thing of like
all this wellness is making me unwell
Fitness is making me unfit this industry
that we're in or this business or this
projected image of who you are we're
supposed to be isn't matching your your
reality in the moment yeah and and how
do you how do you like not shame
yourself over that and just be okay with
it and wait this is for now I'm doing
this thing yes and this will balance out
in this moment yeah in this moment right
in this moment I know that the the back
story like looking the back to the
before and after pictures so many of our
after pictures are in the past
yeah and the one that kills me and just
so ridiculous is new months when you
have a baby what does the fitness
industry tell you to do mmm bounce back
that's like the predominant message
bounce back with this class so you're
supposed to go backwards and not be a
like really the messages don't be a
mother like once you have a child you
are a mother there is an external
measure it's called a baby and your your
your body it's forever change but then
we go to classes to bounce back there's
so much shame in that and it's
absolutely impossible there's no way
we'll ever go back and so again language
conditioning and room and just all of us
I think just remembering how ridiculous
that story is we all know it's
ridiculous and then practicing
remembering oh that doesn't matter right
now matters this moment right this
moment
yeah I move forward gracefully isn't as
catchy no well how about just be alive
in your body right now what do you need
yeah I need to get away from my baby for
40 minutes
ten minutes and move and and be alive in
my body without my baby like that's what
I need you know I don't need to like
reshape my body right or this moment
right that's not really what you need as
a new normal right so there's it's just
it's that constant remembering what we
kind of already know inside so what is
the the state of the fitness industry
now from your estimation like are we are
we doing a better job are we moving in
the right direction yes I do think we
are moving in a really good direction I
the whole idea of empowerment is almost
its big right now it's trending and the
which I like so I think language is
really important language shifts
thoughts become things and so there's a
lot of message about body positivity
even an imagery there's there's all
shapes and sizes when I'm specifically
talking about women that's really really
positive and making a shift and it's
more confusing than ever because when
you look at Instagram which I have a 15
year old daughter and and my son too and
just like and for myself like going
through you we're seeing thousands and
thousands of images 24/7 now it's not
but like it used to be where I'd open
the Victoria's Secret catalog when I was
in high school and pour over those
women's bodies and that's what sexy is
that's what worthy is I remember just
like thinking my body needs to be like
that now it's on your phone and it's the
girl next door or the guy next door with
filters and just slight adjustments and
still objectifying the body but with
positivity in the language right so
there will be like a picture of someone
with like 70,000 likes or whatever and
she's showing a ripped beautiful body
and then in it's a self-acceptance those
are my favorite because it's so
preposterous so consumed transparently
wrong you know but effective obviously
so many people yes she has way more I
mean these way more attention out there
in the world I don't know if it it's
helping and I think they're within good
intentions because they're doing legacy
based stuff and they're building their
own business and I get that and I think
there's just needs to be a general
awareness about it that this social the
the proliferation of imagery is is worse
than it used to be that the forces in
the world are more than the Easter yeah
and I I don't think that we really
understand the implications of this yet
mm-hmm so how does all of that affect
how you parent oh my gosh I feel like
I'm a brand-new parent right now I feel
like I have a baby in a car seat coming
home from the hospital like give me a
manual I don't know what I'm doing his
teenage daughter this is the joke that I
have all the time with Julie I'm like
because we raised together two boys my
stepsons who are now grown and out of
the house and you know it had its
challenges but overall it was like fine
and I thought that I kind of had
parenting figured out and and having a
teenage daughter that's just all out the
window like I am I am completely
ill-equipped to manage this situation
okay so you're no help
yeah I'm asking you misery over our
ineffectiveness I love it though I love
this stage I well first of all I don't
feel like it was that long ago as 15 I
identify with her more I get her uh-huh
um which is kind of alarming right I
some of the things I think about myself
at her age and what I did and how I
behaved and um I just think over and
over again what my mom always tells me
is just see her just keep seeing her and
you know she would she'll share
something with me and I'll really think
about a good response and like just
recently she shared something pretty
important and I responded back and she's
just I thought I did such a good job
she's like mom you sound like an
Instagram ad yeah well you just in the
face we really can't there's nothing you
could say that's gonna be right and I
have for me it's just how can I make
sure that the communication is always
open and doesn't show
it's there if if she's both my kids know
if they need to come to talk to me I'm
going to listen yeah and without shame
and judgement and I think that's harder
for them because I am seen in the public
eye so much and that's really been
confusing I didn't have that I don't
know buddies equip me to be a parent I'm
as a public figure for them to see like
there may be their friends moms know who
I am or people in restaurants come up to
me or that whole thing and then to be in
fitness and that side of it and to be so
successful and to talk about all this
intimate stuff I think that's
contaminating for kids yeah um well Who
am I in this like what is my success
story do I need to live up to that so
that's you know we all did core values I
do this really fun core values exercise
really profound core values exercised at
our retreats and I did it with the
family and we all have our core values
up on the fridge and one of Audrey's is
freedom I think a lot of teenagers
probably share that yeah but I really
think that is her that's gonna stick
with her forever and I always have to
remember that that her core value is
freedom freedom and defining who she is
freedom and rules freedom in general and
honoring that yeah that's cool I might
try that it was really my daughter to
write down her core values you might
just pivot and walk away from me
yeah you got maybe third party yet how
do you deliver that message oh that's
great I think what was I gonna say you
know I I think that it's really hard to
be a teenager right now you know it's a
very confusing time and the more
compassion that I can be about that and
just be a good listener mm-hmm
the better off I am going to be yeah and
it's cliche and I know it's true how we
show up is how they learn yeah in the
in-between moments not in the talk like
the big talks or the you know the
Instagram moment when she said you sound
like an Instagram that's not really when
she's gonna learn anyways it's my
behaviors you know how I am your yeah
yeah does your daughter
our classes it now that her friends
think it's cool
you know that I think that that that's
cool that she gets to go with her
friends yeah yeah she's an incredible
athlete she's soccer player that's cool
yeah she's a fun elite alright well
let's uh let's land this plane maybe we
can close it out with just a few
thoughts for the budding women
entrepreneurs out there or any
entrepreneur for for that matter I
suppose people who are looking to create
something like what are some words of
wisdom that you can close this down with
are you already are creating in this
moment and that just the idea or the
thought is a creation right and um so
that's one you're already creating
you're already there you're already
doing it it's a practice it'll always be
like that and trusting that and honoring
that versus I'm not good enough I'm not
there yet I haven't done it yet I don't
know how to do it I can't do that
why would I Who am I to start my own
fitness concept right it's well if
you're thinking about it you're already
at the craving second is trut you
already know the answers over and over
again in my experience when I scratch my
own itch there's other people like me
that have that same image and to know
that a data point of one is also really
important than a statistical survey over
across millions specifically if you're
creating something out of a problem that
is personal for you which I think a lot
of people in fitness that's how it
happens and then I would say the third
is to be open to learning and just
surrounding yourself with people who you
can learn from and grow with and who
make you uncomfortable just enough where
you're you're failing and falling
forward and and getting back up again
and getting back up again and getting
back up in in a safe space communities q
I like that idea of the N of one like
like trusting like if you are sort of
integrated enough where you can trust
that intuitive voice
to understand that just because you
might be the only one who's feeling that
that that's still valid like that's what
Hollywood is built on somebody has an
idea for a movie because this is the
movie they want to see and they make it
into the work you know they like that's
how everything began great products
great products and businesses start if
people tell you if you share your idea
and people say oh that would never work
great that means it's probably awesome
right
because maybe not always but I would be
careful with that well but then who
cares try it like there's a sense of
like just go do if you really think and
you know why not like give it a go I I
just saw Sarah Blake please speak who
did Spanx yeah yeah her husband's a good
friend of mine I was just here she's
awesome and nobody thought her idea was
great you're gonna cut off pantyhose
like right that's it she's like know it
perfect it's nobody gets it yet right
and I think there is something to that
same with me I'm like yeah I want to do
a fitness I don't want to call it
fitness and I want it to be about
relationships and community and fighting
lonely and I don't want it to be
attached to a heritage and I want
everybody to do their own thing in a
group and work like all these things
that people are like that's doesn't work
that's not group exercise that's not
Fitness I'm not gonna have a sales team
I'm not going to you know advertise
uh-huh well you're not gonna get off the
ground it's not gonna work
and but we just shut out all the
business books all the noise everything
we learned a 20.per fitness obviously we
shut out and that's how far three
letters came into the world
yeah it's cool Sarah's hilarious oh my
gosh do you follow her on Instagram now
I do I was the best
she's so authentic did you see the video
that she put up where she's in some
boardroom and there's like oil paintings
of all these stuffy men that had like
we're barons of the underwear industry
going back you know like a hundred years
or something like that and she's like
you're telling me this guy's gonna tell
me what kind of underwear I should be
where it was the it's the funniest so
true
and so true yeah she's wonderful all
right well this was lovely thank you so
so fun yeah I appreciate it I want to go
to a class now what you know only I'll
be the only guy there might be one or
two yes
yeah I gotta feel started you away I'm
right around here somewhere I'll tell
you honestly the men who come our
athletes yeah okay surprise it'sit's a
really good most of them are rock
climbers and cyclists and uh-huh
basketball players we have MBA
basketball players doing bar 3 um so
yeah it's usually the athletic Bunch
think that can work through the the
anxiety of gosh they're gonna be all
women which is always you know it's
universally women feel the same way I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be the only one that
looks like this I'm not gonna be
coordinating us flexible enough that's
every single I've never met someone that
didn't feel that way walking into the
studio yeah all right well I will go and
I will report back okay awesome so if
you're diggin on Sadie you can find a
class near you at bar 3.com is it that's
the website right dar re3 and if people
want to connect with you what's the best
way Instagram Sadie Lincoln yeah yeah
that's it yeah good that's it all right
yeah thank you
right to you Thank You bhai peace of
plans
[Music]